بمجرد أن يستعد ، لا يخلع خوان كارلوس كروز
غونزاليس معداته
في محرقة الجثث حيث يعمل
في مقبرة عامة ، لا يوجد وقت توقف
بين الجثث بصراحة ،
لقد انتهى هذا الوباء ، يقول إنه لا يزال يحدث
كل يوم لم تفعله الأفران  توقفوا عن إطلاق النار
في الساعات التي كنا فيها هناك ، لكنهم
لم يتمكنوا من الحفاظ على بعض العائلات التي
أحضرت أحباءها واضطروا إلى الانتظار
لساعات حتى يتم حرقهم ، إنه
توضيح مزعج أن وباء المكسيك
لم ينته بعد
والأرقام تدعم ذلك
يوضح الرسم البياني الاتجاه اليومي للحالات الجديدة من
فيروس كورونا في المكسيك ، ليس من
الصعب رؤية أن الأمور تزداد
سوءًا ،
لذا فإن إعادة فتح الاقتصاد أمر خطير ،
سألنا نعم ، خوان كارلوس يقول إنه لا يزال من السابق
لأوانه العودة إلى طبيعته لكن
رئيس المكسيك  لا يتفق معه ، يقول إنه
يتعين علينا العودة شيئًا فشيئًا
بعناية لممارسة حريتنا.
بدأ العمل في معظم
أنحاء البلاد في شهر يونيو ، حيث أرسل
مئات الآلاف إلى العمل
في مختلف الصناعات ، ولديه
الكثير من الدعم في سوق البيع بالجملة الضخم في مدينة مكسيكو سيتي ،
حيث انخفضت مبيعات رودولفو ماتشادو
بنسبة 70 ٪ منذ بدء تفشي المرض ،
ونريد أن يذهب الجميع  بالعودة إلى طبيعتها ،
يقول إن شهورًا من الحجر الصحي ،
فقد زاد عدد القتلى في المكسيك بأكثر من
الضعف في الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية فقط ،
ويتوقع نموذج من معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا أنه قد يتجاوز 50
ألفًا بحلول أوائل أغسطس والعودة
داخل محرقة الجثث بحيث يصبح عدد القتلى
حقيقيًا من الخمسة  الجثث التي رأيناها تم إحضارها
إلى أربعة كانت على الأرجح وفيات مرتبطة بـ كوبان 19
أولئك الذين يعملون هنا.
مع العلم أنه من خلال
القيام بذلك ، هناك فرصة كبيرة لأن
تصبح المقابر مثل هذه المقابر
أكثر امتلاءً من أنهار مات سي إن إن خارج المكسيك
سي  مدينة